you mentioned reinforcement learning
so you've have uh a couple of years in
the field
no uh quite you know
quite a few uh quite a long career
in artificial intelligence broadly but
reinforcement learning specifically
can you maybe give a hint about your
sense
of the history of the field and in some
ways has changed with the
advent of deep learning but has a long
roots like how is it
weaved in and out of your own life how
have you seen the community change or
maybe the ideas that it's playing with
change
i've had the privilege the pleasure of
being of having almost a front row seat
to a lot of this stuff and it's been
really
really fun and interesting so when i was
in college in the 80s
early 80s the neural net
thing was starting to happen and i was
taking a lot of psychology classes a lot
of computer science classes
as a college student and i thought you
know something that can play tic-tac-toe
and just like learn to get better at it
that ought to be a really easy thing so
i spent almost
almost all of my what would have been
vacations during college
like hacking on my home computer trying
to teach it how to play tic-tac-toe and
programming language basic oh yeah
that's that's i was i
that's my first language that's my
native language is that when you first
fell in love with computer science just
like programming basic on that
uh what was what was the computer do you
remember i had i had a trs-80
model one before they were called model
ones because there was nothing else uh
i got my computer in 1979.
uh instead so i was it was i would have
been bar mitzvahed
but instead of having a big party that
my parents threw on my behalf
they just got me a computer because
that's what i really really really
wanted i saw him in the
in the in the mall in radio shack and i
thought
what how are they doing that i would try
to stump them i would give them math
problems like
one plus and then in parentheses two
plus one yeah and i would always get it
right i'm like
how do you know so much message like
i've had to go to algebra class for the
last few years to learn this stuff and
you just seem to know
so i was i was i was smitten and i got a
computer and i think ages
13 to 15
i have no memory of those years i think
i just was in my room
with the computer listening to billy
joel communing possibly listening to the
radio listening to billy joel
that was the one album i had uh on vinyl
at that time
and um and then i got it on cassette
tape and that was really helpful
because then i could play it i didn't
have to go down to my parents wi-fi or
hi-fi
sorry uh and at age 15 i remember kind
of walking out and like okay
i'm ready to talk to people again like
i've learned what i need to learn here
and um so yeah so so that was that was
my home computer and so i went to
college and i was like i'm totally going
to study computer science and i opted
the college i chose specifically had a
computer science major
the one that i really wanted the college
i really wanted to go to didn't so
bye-bye to them which college did you go
through so i went to yale
uh princeton would have been way more
convenient and it was just beautiful
campus and it was close enough to home
and i was really excited about princeton
and i visited
i said so computer science major like
well we have computer engineering i'm
like oh i don't like that word
engineering
i like computer science i really i want
to do like you're saying hardware and
software they're like yeah i'm like i
just want to do software i i couldn't
care less about hardware you grew up in
philadelphia i grew up outside philly
yeah yeah okay
uh so the you know local schools were
like penn and drexel
and uh temple like everyone in my family
went to temple at least at one point in
their lives except for me
so yeah philly philly family yale had a
computer science department and that's
when you
it's kind of interesting you said 80s
and neural networks that's when you know
that which was a hot new thing or a hot
thing period uh so what is that in
college when you first learned about
neural networks yeah
yeah which you learned like it was in a
psychology class not in a cs
wow yeah was it psychology or cognitive
science or like do you remember
like what context it was yeah yeah yeah
so so
i was a i've always been a bit of a
cognitive psychology groupie
so like i studied computer science but i
like i like to hang around where the
cognitive
scientists are because i don't know
brains man they're like
they're wacky cool and they have a
bigger picture view of things they're a
little less engineery i would say
they're more
they're more interested in the nature of
cognition and intelligence and
perception and called like the vision
system work
they're asking always bigger questions
now with the deep learning community
there i think
more there's a lot of intersections but
i do find in
that the the neuroscience folks actually
and uh cognitive psychology cognitive
science folks
are starting to learn how to program how
to use your own artificial neural
networks
and they are actually approaching
problems in like totally new interesting
ways
it's fun to watch that grad students
from those departments
like approach the problem of machine
learning right they come in with a
different perspective
yeah they don't care about like your
imagine that data set or whatever
they they want like to understand the
the like
the basic mechanisms at the
at the neuronal level at the functional
level of intelligence it's kind of
it's kind of cool to see them work but
yeah okay so
you always lo you were always a group
you have cognitive psychology
yeah yeah and so uh so it was in a class
by richard garrick he was kind of my
my favorite uh psych professor in
college and i took
uh like three different classes with him
and
yeah so that we they were talking
specifically the class i think was kind
of a
there was a big paper that was written
by stephen pinker and
uh prince i don't i'm blanking on
prince's first name but prince and
pinker and prince
they wrote kind of uh uh they were at
that time
kind of like ah i'm liking on the names
of the current people
um the cognitive scientists who are
complaining a lot about deep networks
oh uh gary uh gary marcus sorry marcus
and who else i mean there's a few but
gary gary's the most feisty
sure gary's very feisty and with this
with his co-author they they you know
they're kind of
doing these kind of takedowns where they
say okay well yeah it does all these
amazing amazing things but
here's a shortcoming here's a
shortcoming here's your chart coming and
so the pinker prince paper
is kind of like the that generation's
version
of marcus and davis right where they're
they're
trained as cognitive scientists but
they're looking skeptically at the
results in the
in the artificial intelligence neural
net kind of world and saying
yeah it can do this and this and this
but like it can't do that and it can't
do that and it can't do that
maybe in principle or maybe just in
practice at this point but but the fact
of the matter is
you're you've narrowed your focus too
far
to be impressed you know you're
impressed with the things within that
circle
but you need to broaden that circle a
little bit you need to look at a wider
set of problems
and so um so we have so i was in this
seminar in college
that was basically a close reading of
the pinker prince paper
which was like really thick there was a
lot going on in there
and um and and it talked about
the reinforcement learning idea a little
bit i'm like oh that sounds really cool
because behavior is what is really
interesting to me about
psychology anyway so making programs
that i mean programs are things that
behave
people are things that behave like i
want to make learning that learns to
behave
in which way was reinforcement learning
presented is this uh talking about
human and animal behavior or are we
talking about actual mathematical
constructs ah that's a great so that's a
good question right so this is
i think it wasn't actually talked about
as behavior in the paper that i was
reading i think that it just talked
about learning
and to me learning is about learning to
behave but really
neural nets at that point were about
learning like supervised learning so
learning to produce outputs from inputs
so i kind of tried to invent
reinforcement learning
i uh when i graduated i joined a
research group at
bellcore which had spun out of bell labs
recently at that time because of the
divestiture of the
of long distance and local phone service
in the 1980s 1984
and i was in a group uh with dave ackley
who was the first author of the
boltzmann machine paper so the very
first neural net paper that could handle
xor right so xor sort of killed neural
nets the very first the zero with the
first winter
yeah um the the perceptrons paper
and hinton along with his student dave
ackley and
and i think there was other authors as
well showed that no no with both
machines we can actually learn
non-linear concepts and so everything's
back on the table again and that kind of
started that second wave of neural
networks
so dave ackley was he became my mentor
at bellcore and we
talked a lot about learning and life and
computation and how all these things get
together
now dave and i have a podcast together
so um so i get to
kind of enjoy that sort of
his his perspective uh once again even
even all these years later
and so i said so i said i was really
interested in
learning but in the concept of behavior
and he's like oh well that's
reinforcement learning
here and he gave me rich sutton's 1984
td paper
so i read that paper i honestly didn't
get all of it but i got the idea i got
that they were using
that he was using ideas that i was
familiar with in the context of neural
nets and
and like sort of backprop but
with this idea of making predictions
over time i'm like this is so
interesting but i don't really get all
the details i said to dave and dave said
oh well why don't we have him come and
give a talk
and i was like wait what you can do that
like these are real people
i thought they were just words i thought
it was just like ideas that somehow
magically seeped into paper he's like no
i
i i know rich like we'll just have him
come down and
and he'll give a talk and so i was you
know
my mind was blown and so rich came and
he gave a talk at bellcore
and he talked about what he was super
excited which was they had just figured
out at the time
uh q-learning so watkins had visited
the rich sutton's lab at at umass or
it's andy barto's lab that rich was a
part of
and um he was really excited about this
because it resolved a whole bunch of
problems that he didn't know how to
resolve in the
in the earlier paper and so uh
for people who don't know td temporal
difference it's these are all just
algorithms for reinforcement learning
right and td separate difference in
particular is about making predictions
over time
and you can try to use it for making
decisions right because if you can
predict how good a future
action and action outcomes will be in
the future you can choose one that has
better and
but the theory didn't really support
changing your behavior like the
predictions had to be of a consistent
process if you really
wanted it to work and one of the things
that was really cool about
q-learning another algorithm for
reinforcement learning is it was off
policy which meant that you could
actually be learning about the
environment and what
the value of different actions would be
while actually figuring out how to
behave
optimally yeah so that was a revelation
yeah and the proof of that is kind of
interesting i mean that's really
surprising to me when i first
read that and then enriched rich
sutton's book on the matter
it's it's kind of beautiful that a
single equation can capture one equation
one line of code and like you can learn
anything
yeah like enough time so equation and
code you're right like
you can the code that you can
arguably at least if you like squint
your eyes
can say this is all of intelligence
is that you can implement that and i'll
sing well i think i started with lisp
which is uh
shout out to lisp uh like a single line
of code
key piece of code maybe a couple that
you could do that
it's kind of magical it's uh feels too
good to be true
well and it sort of is yeah it's kind of
kind of
it seems to require an awful lot of
extra stuff supporting it but
yeah but nonetheless the idea is the the
idea is really good and as far as we
know
it is it is a very reasonable way of
trying to create
adaptive behavior behavior that gets
better at something over time
did you find the idea of optimal uh at
all compelling that
you could prove that it's optimal so
like one part of computer science
that it makes people feel warm and fuzzy
inside
is when you can prove something like
that a sorting algorithm worst case runs
and
n log n and it makes everybody feel so
good even though in reality it doesn't
really matter what the worst case is
what matters is like
does this thing actually work in
practice on this particular actual set
of data that i
that i enjoy did you so here's that
here's a place where i have maybe a
strong opinion uh oh which is like
you're right of course but no no
like so so the what makes worst case so
great right if you have a worst case
analysis so great is that you get
modularity you can take that thing and
plug it into another thing
and still have some understanding of
what's going to happen when you
click them together right if it just
works well in practice
in other words with respect to some
distribution that you care about
when you go plug it into another thing
that distribution can shift
it can change and your thing may not
work well anymore and you want it to
and you wish it does and you hope that
it will but it might not and then
ah so you're so so you're saying you
don't like
uh machine learning
but we have some positive theoretical
results for these things
you know you can come back at me with
yeah but they're really weak and yeah
they're really weak and and you can even
say that
you know sorting algorithms like if you
do the optimal sorting algorithm it's
not really the one that you want
and that might be true as well but but
it is the modularity is a really
powerful statement
really as an engineer you can then
assemble different things you can count
on them to be
i mean it's interesting it's it's a
balance
like with everything else in life you
don't want to get too obsessed i mean
this is what computer scientists do
which they
potentially get obsessed they over
optimize things
or they start by optimizing them they
over optimize yeah so it's
it's easy to like get really granular
about this thing
but like the step from an n squared
to an n log n sorting algorithm is a big
leap
for most real world systems no matter
what the actual
behavior of the system is that's a big
leap and the same can probably be
said for other kind of first uh
leaps that you would take on a
particular problem like it's the
picking the low hanging fruit or
whatever the equivalent of
doing the not the dumbest thing but the
next to the dumbest thing is
picking the most delicious reachable
fruit yeah most delicious reachable
fruit i don't know why that's not a
saying
and yeah okay so
uh so you then this is the 80s
and this kind of idea starts to
percolate of uh
yeah at that point i got to re i got to
meet rich sutton so everything was sort
of downhill from there and that was that
was really the pinnacle of everything
um but then i you know then i felt like
i was kind of on the inside so then
as interesting results were happening i
could like check in with
with rich or with jerry tesaro who had a
huge impact on
uh kind of early thinking in in temporal
difference learning and reinforcement
learning and showed that you could do
you could solve problems that we didn't
know how to solve any other way
um and so that was really cool so was
good things were happening i would hear
about it from
either the people who were doing it or
the people who were talking to the
people who are doing it
and so i was able to track things pretty
well through through the 90s
so what uh wasn't most of the
excitement on reinforcement learning in
the 90s era with
what is it td gamma like what's the role
of these kind of little like fun game
playing things and breakthroughs about
uh get
you know exciting the community was that
like what were your
because uh you've also built across or
we're part of building a crossword
a puzzle uh solver program yeah
solving program uh called proverb
so so you were interested in this as
a problem like in forming
using games to understand how to build
uh intelligent systems so like what did
you think about tt gamble like what did
you think about that whole thing in the
90s yeah i mean i found the td gammon
result really just remarkable so i had
known about some of jerry's stuff before
he did td gammon he did a
system just more vanilla well not not
entirely vanilla but a more classical
back proppy kind of
uh network for playing back admin where
he was training it on
expert moves so it was kind of
supervised but the way that it worked
was not to
mimic the actions but to learn
internally an evaluation function so to
learn
well if the expert chose this over this
that must mean that the expert values
this more than this
and so let me adjust my weights to make
it so that the network
evaluates this as being better than this
so it could learn
from from human preferences it could
learn its own preferences
and then when he took the step from that
to actually
doing it as a full-on reinforcement
learning problem where you didn't need a
trainer you could just let it play
that was that was remarkable right and
so i think
as as humans often do as we've done
in the recent past as well people
extrapolate it's like oh well if you can
do that which is obviously very hard
then obviously you could do all these
other problems that we
that we want to solve that we know are
also really hard
and it turned out very few of them ended
up being practical
partly because i think neural nets
certainly at the time
were struggling to be consistent and
reliable and so training them in a
reinforcement learning setting was a bit
of a mess
i had uh i don't know generation after
generation of
like master students who wanted to do
value function approximation basically
learned reinforcement learning
with neural nets and
over and over and over again we were
failing we couldn't get
the good results that jerry tessaro got
i now believe that jerry
is a neural net whisperer he has a
particular
ability to get neural networks to do
things that other people would find
impossible and it's not the technology
it's the technology
and jerry together yeah and which i
think
speaks to the role of the human expert
in the process of machine learning right
it's so easy we're
so drawn to the idea that that it's the
technology that is that
is where the power is coming from that i
think we lose sight of the fact that
sometimes you need a really good
just like i mean no one would think hey
here's this great piece of software
here's like i don't know gnu emacs or
whatever
um doesn't that prove that computers are
super powerful and
basically going to take over the world
it's like no starman is a hell of a
hacker right so he was able to make
the code do these amazing things he
couldn't have done it without the
computer
but the computer couldn't have done it
without him and so i think people
discount
the role of people like jerry who who
who have just a particular particular
set of skills
you